hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm marie
and we hit 20,000 subscribers oh the
real rejects let's hit 20,000
subscribers it's been quite the journey
marie
and my neighbor has been here to support
me for the past like nine months and
she's come on the channel the help and
she's great so I figured why not she's
right next door
gonna put her next to me right now cuz
she's the best she's the best people
don't know this but I love Marie I love
you thank you
I couldn't get everyone to be here for
this but you know it's funny because a
lot of people were predicting that by
the end of summer we would have 10,000
subscribers and [ __ ] owned it it's
still July [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] the
humble [ __ ] it's all about owning on
some Ava's ex-girlfriend's family
doubted me what up now what up now I
miss you so much come back to me but
really don't you're a good person if
you're watching yeah I wanted to say
thank you guys I mean if you're if
you're new um like recently subscribed
yes I hope you continue to stay
subscribed because we're gonna have a
good journey here gonna have a good time
so what marine are gonna do is we're
gonna call some people and you know some
other rejects on the channel and see if
they pick up and let's see if they
noticed if we have 20,000 subscribers
ready for this marine who should we call
first ELISA has been on the videos on
the channel the most out of all of them
yeah let's call ELISA yeah that's true
but I'll probably be too lazy to do that
calling Alyssa right now oh you mean on
the phone yeah they even write down for
the big camera none of these girls pick
up you know that it's part of the
process they only answer me in text
messages
what'd I tell you what'd I tell you here
we go
hey Alyssa its it's Ryan I I really need
to talk to you
there's just something that I just I
just need to talk to you could you call
me back when you get this message
Thanks yeah she'll call back I don't
know Claud Veronica now Veronica
Veronica
I'm here with Murray are you I'm good
I'm calling you because we hit 20,000
subscribers and right now I'm doing a
video I just wanted you to say a little
thank you for them that was great
no Thank You Veronica um listen you get
back to masturbating to me I got to I
got it I got a call everyone else now
Lauren gah we gotta call the the gah one
of the most awkward with my cuz I'm like
so attractive lady she's too pretty she
should be killed for being that pretty
gosh yeah that escalated quickly someone
could say
I know so it doesn't that I was mom yeah
she's not gonna answer she's not gonna
answer you could always tell when
someone's not gonna answer after like 20
seconds no one answers the hit we ignore
buddy hey Lauren its Ryan and Marie and
we hit 20,000 subscribers so I'm just
doing a little video right now for the
subs for saying thank you and I wanted
to catch you on the phone so you can say
a little message - but you didn't pick
up never pick up your phone
you're always ignoring me I gave you
everything I gave you my soul i bared my
heart to you and what did you do you
don't even pick up your goddamn phone
what the hell Lauren how many times I've
masturbated to you so many times 27 to
be exact you guess I'm gonna say see you
next week
see you there buddy hope you're having a
good weekend 20,000 yay
thanks Lauren you've been a great help
it's - did it answer picks up let's go
damn
I told you to what answers they're
[ __ ] over me don't care to hear your
voicemail Dan don't care your your
voicemail huh
I love how there's a voicemail and then
there's that hey Dan it's Ryan I'm doing
a little video right now Murray saying
thank you to the twenty thousand subs so
I'm just calling up everyone you're the
third person I answered you guys are
really contributing to making this video
horrible right now this is going to be a
big letdown to a lot of people people
are gonna be I think the word would be
disappointed would you agree with that
yeah disappointed is the word and you
are contributing to the disappointment
of the video so thanks Dan Thanks I'm
sorry I'm taking out my sex issues out
on you I haven't had sex in a while Dan
and I just I feel so lonely hey Murray
what's she doing tonight Murray you
don't want to spend the night here no
we're gonna we're gonna go to UM to a
bowling alley private bowling alley we
have to have a membership to be there so
I mean you know it's like I get it we're
not gonna have sex Murray just probably
hang up the phone on ya right now this
videos turning wonderful
I hope cat doesn't corner me into a
conversation I'm making her look really
good before I call her
Jesus Christ geez you know you'll work
with them all the time and they never
pick up their phone hey cat dass its
Ryan I and I'm here with Murray cat I
was thinking about you and your sexy
body and I just really wanted to you
know well I want her to lick you not in
your vagina on your face let's make that
clear although if you were okay we're
not gonna go there
anyway we hit 20,000 subscribers and I'm
doing a little thank-you video right now
and I wanted to call up all the rejects
you know show how close we are what a
tight-knit community we have how we're
always there for each other like how we
are all like really best friends and you
are like the fifth person to not answer
their phone so thank you thank you for
that Kat dose you're probably busy being
at the beach with guys admiring you or
something I don't know she does have an
incredible body guys have you seen her
body yeah you show me photos Facebook
photos right yeah find her Facebook Joe
calling Jeremy right now hey we got
[ __ ] 20,000 subscribers 20 God 2,000
subscribers
oh yeah it can get confusing I forget Oh
Adele Adele my pickup
Adele tends to pick up her phone [ __ ]
Adele I don't know she can't accept
calls at this time
hey a lot of you guys been asking even
though I've explained this in several
videos Sally we we fired her from the
channel
she was a [ __ ] terrible person and we
kicked her out you guys don't know the
real her no that's not what happened at
all
she decided that she wants to focus more
on pursuing television work
she needs such an ass
um no she's a great actress and she's
pursuing television right now and then
she's gonna be focusing on school
so she's no longer the third member but
she is gonna be a country occurring on
the channel every now and again I'm
probably not for a little while but she
will still come on the channel every now
and again my heart salamander you had
the best tasting fish I've ever had fish
yeah she cooked me a fish it wasn't of a
giant reference she cooked me fish you
never know that I've gone down on girls
who have not blown me I didn't go down
Sally now I would have liked to go down
on Sally well you would have liked to go
down on a lot of girls yeah I mean I
would have liked to go down Sally
Alyssa Veronica Lauren Adele Kat not you
well so why are you pursuing that box
that no one watches from it's all
YouTube now you're so beautiful this is
the longest thank you video that anyone
has ever done so thank you guys
hopefully you enjoyed the non
conversations that we had with all the
other rejects and should I say something
motivational go get them tiger yeah go
go get him tiger you know bring back the
gold let's let's keep sharing the videos
and keep commenting and let's let's get
to thirty thousand that's motivating us
that's motivating motivate them to bring
us money
yeah click the ad would you man if you
don't have a t-shirt oh dude yeah I so
see where you're coming from on this
right anyway
you just look at my lips when I was
talking did you want to kiss me get out
of here get out of here you sick
disgusting Pig of a human no oh thanks
for making out really really is that
we're really thinking yeah are you
joking or is that we really think you
know I'm afraid trading my teeth sorry
hi I am a YouTube celebrity I have to be
good-looking 20,000 people don't call me
an [ __ ] Do You Know Who I am
I run the internet now
PewDiePie ain't got nothing on me
okay this video